This spring, denim gets a softer, lighter update. Introducing Old Navy's drapey denim wide leg, a new fit that moves with you. It's everything you want denim to feel like for summer. Easy, breathable, and effortlessly cool. With a fit that creates natural movement and a wide leg that feels modern, not overwhelming. Plus, that signature, wait, for this price, moment. Old Navy's drapey denim wide leg. Think about the sweetness of a strawberry or the satisfying,
今年春天，牛仔裤迎来了一次更柔软、更轻盈的升级。隆重推出 Old Navy 的垂坠感阔腿牛仔裤，这是一款能随你而动的全新版型。它满足了你对夏季牛仔裤的所有期待：舒适、透气，且毫不费力地展现酷感。这种版型能营造出自然的动感，阔腿设计既现代又不显臃肿。此外，它还有那种标志性的“等等，这个价格？”的惊喜时刻。Old Navy 垂坠感阔腿牛仔裤。想想草莓的甜美，或者令人满足的，
crunch of a potato chip. What makes these things taste so good? You might think it's just sugar, salt, and fat, but research suggests that it's more than that. The color of the strawberry, the sound of the potato chip crunch, even the place where you're eating can all contribute to how you experience each bite. Psychologists have long studied the senses individually, but in the real world, sight, sound, taste, smell, and touch are constantly interacting. Today we're going to talk to a psychologist who studies multi-sensory perception about how our senses work together to shape how we perceive and taste the world. So how does the brain combine information from different senses to create our global perceptions?
薯片的酥脆感。是什么让这些东西吃起来如此美味？你可能认为仅仅是因为糖、盐和脂肪，但研究表明，原因远不止于此。草莓的颜色、薯片咀嚼时的声音，甚至你进食的地点，都会影响你对每一口的体验。心理学家长期以来一直在单独研究各种感官，但在现实世界中，视觉、听觉、味觉、嗅觉和触觉是在不断相互作用的。今天，我们将与一位研究多感官感知的心理学家探讨我们的感官是如何协同工作，从而塑造我们感知和品尝世界的方式。那么，大脑是如何结合来自不同感官的信息来创造我们的整体感知的呢？
What are some of the most surprising ways that our senses interact? And how can you use this knowledge to eat healthier, enjoy more food, and otherwise improve your life? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is Dr. Charles Spence, a professor of experimental psychology at the University of Oxford,
我们感官互动中最令人惊讶的方式有哪些？你如何利用这些知识来吃得更健康、享受更多美食，并改善你的生活？欢迎收听《心理学谈话》，这是美国心理学会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯。我今天的嘉宾是牛津大学实验心理学教授查尔斯·斯彭斯博士，
where he heads the cross-modal research laboratory. He's published hundreds of academic papers on multisensory perception. He also brings his knowledge out of the lab and into the world. He's consulted for many multinational companies on product design, packaging, and branding. He's worked with chefs to design foods that maximally stimulate the senses, and he's helped car companies design multi-sensory warning signals for drivers. Dr. Spence has won many awards for his work, including a 2008 Ig Nobel Prize for Research That Makes You Laugh and Then Makes You Think.
他在那里领导着跨模态研究实验室。他发表了数百篇关于多感官感知的学术论文。他还将自己的知识从实验室带到了现实世界。他曾为许多跨国公司提供产品设计、包装和品牌推广方面的咨询。他与厨师合作设计能最大限度刺激感官的食物，并帮助汽车公司为驾驶员设计多感官警告信号。斯彭斯博士因其工作获得了许多奖项，包括 2008 年的“搞笑诺贝尔奖”，该奖项旨在表彰那些“先让你发笑，然后让你思考”的研究。
He's also author of the book's Gastrophysics, The New Science of Eating, and Sense Hacking, How to Use the Power of Your Senses for Healthy, Happier Living. Dr. Spence, thank you for joining me today. Thank you. So I just mentioned that you direct the cross-modal research laboratory, at Oxford. So let's start there. What does cross-modal mean in your research? So as a psychologist who studies the senses, sound, touch, taste and smell, spend most of my time thinking about how the senses relate one to another. And the sort of two words that we use regularly are cross-modal on the one
他还是《美食物理学：饮食的新科学》和《感官黑客：如何利用感官的力量实现更健康、更快乐的生活》这两本书的作者。斯彭斯博士，感谢您今天加入我的节目。谢谢。我刚才提到您在牛津大学指导跨模态研究实验室。那么我们从这里开始吧。在您的研究中，“跨模态”是什么意思？作为一名研究感官（声音、触觉、味觉和嗅觉）的心理学家，我大部分时间都在思考感官之间是如何相互关联的。我们经常使用的两个词是“跨模态”和
hand and multi-sensory on the other. Some people, many people use those terms interchangeably. but to those who've spent their lifetime thinking about the ways that the senses can interact. Multisensaries take to mean when things kind of come together into one unified gestal to a whole. So maybe the flavour of food
“多感官”。有些人，很多人，把这两个术语互换使用。但对于那些花了一辈子时间思考感官如何互动的人来说，多感官是指当事物融合在一起，形成一个统一的整体（格式塔）时。比如，食物的风味
has taste and it has smell, texture, all of those things come together into one unified flavor, which is multi-sensory. I contrast that with sort of cross-modal cases where, for example, if I suddenly slapped my hands together, that sudden light noise will make the light
既有味觉，又有嗅觉、质地，所有这些结合在一起形成了一种统一的风味，这就是多感官。我将其与“跨模态”的情况进行对比，例如，如果我突然拍手，那突如其来的响声会让你觉得周围的光线
seem brighter wherever you are. You don't integrate that clapping sound with the lights, but nevertheless, the sounds cross-modally affect visual perception. So the things kind of stay separate and yet one influences the other. And over the last 30 years, I've spent a lot of time thinking about these cross-modal and multi-sensory effects, starting in the lab and then going out into the real world to see where they apply and then coming back into the lab again to study them some more. All right. Well, we'll get around to talking about that, but I want to start by noting that most of your work has focused on food and taste. Why is eating such a powerful example of multi-sensory perception? So I guess eating and drinking is something that we all do. So it's a shared
似乎更亮了。你并没有把拍手声和光线整合在一起，但尽管如此，声音还是跨模态地影响了视觉感知。所以事物保持独立，但一个又影响了另一个。在过去的 30 年里，我花了很多时间思考这些跨模态和多感官效应，从实验室开始，然后走进现实世界看看它们在哪里适用，然后再回到实验室进行更多的研究。好的，我们会谈到这一点，但我首先想指出，您的大部分工作都集中在食物和味觉上。为什么饮食是多感官感知的一个强有力的例子？我想，吃喝是我们所有人都会做的事情。所以这是一个共同的
interest, something we all do several times a day normally. And it is probably one of the most multi-sensory things that we do. I mean, watching TV, that's got sort of sound and it's got sight, but smell-o-vision's never gone very far. We can't taste the TV yet. So, It's multi-sensory, but only with a few, whereas food and drink are kind of inherently stimulate all of the senses. They have a certain visual appearance that might look good on Instagram. They have the sound of the crunch or the crack or the snap or the crack or the pop to stimulate our ears, the mouth fields of oral touch, the texture of food, the spiciness, another sense,
兴趣，是我们每天通常会做几次的事情。而且它可能是我们所做的最具有多感官特征的事情之一。我的意思是，看电视，它有声音和视觉，但“嗅觉电视”从未走远。我们还不能品尝电视。所以，它是多感官的，但只有少数几种，而食物和饮料本质上会刺激所有的感官。它们有一种视觉外观，在 Instagram 上可能看起来不错。它们有咀嚼、碎裂、崩裂或爆裂的声音来刺激我们的耳朵，有口腔触觉带来的口感，食物的质地，辛辣味，另一种感官，
a pungency of pepper, the burn of chili through, what have I missed there, the smell of it and the basic tastes of sweet and sour and salty and bitter, and all of those things, not every time, but very often all of those senses are kind of brought together to contribute to what we think of. What we describe as a taste of food, but really we mean the flavor of food or the flavor I'd like to introduce. I love the flavor of that would be much better descriptive
胡椒的刺激感，辣椒的灼烧感，我还漏了什么吗？嗅觉，以及甜、酸、咸、苦的基本味觉，所有这些，虽然不是每次，但通常所有这些感官都会汇集在一起，促成我们所认为的。我们将其描述为食物的“味道”，但实际上我们指的是食物的“风味”。我更愿意引入“风味”这个词。我喜欢那种风味，这比
than I love the taste of it, because taste to the sort of the food scientist would narrowly mean just what you get on your tongue, which would be sort of sweet, sour, bitter, salty, umamium, maybe a few other things. Now, you found that sound can influence taste, something that you call sonic seasoning. How does that work? And maybe you could explain your sonic chip experiments as part of the answer.
“我喜欢它的味道”要好得多，因为对于食品科学家来说，“味道”狭义上仅指你在舌头上感受到的东西，也就是甜、酸、苦、咸、鲜，也许还有其他一些东西。现在，您发现声音可以影响味觉，您称之为“声音调味”。这是如何运作的？也许您可以解释一下您的“声音薯片”实验作为答案的一部分。
Yes. Fortunately or unfortunately, my father's no longer with us, but he would always, when he heard me talking about the sonic chip, go not the sonic chip again. He was tired of hearing about it, but maybe not everyone has. And this was work we did back in 2004. Got the Ig Nobel Prize for Nutrition in 2008 for a study. we brought 20 hungry undergraduates into the lab in Oxford, the crossmodal research lab, gave each of them two tubes of pringles to munch on and put them in a soundproof box with the
是的。幸运或不幸的是，我父亲已经不在了，但他每次听到我谈论“声音薯片”时，总是会说：“别又是那个声音薯片了。”他听腻了，但也许不是每个人都听过。这是我们在 2004 年所做的工作。因这项研究获得了 2008 年营养学领域的搞笑诺贝尔奖。我们将 20 名饥肠辘辘的本科生带到牛津的跨模态研究实验室，给他们每人两筒品客薯片，让他们在隔音箱里吃，并配有
microphone. And each time they bit into one of those pringles, we take the sound, pick it up from the microphone, take it outside, transform it a bit, make it louder or quieter, boost just the high frequencies or suppress them in the crunching sound and then play them back over headphones. and we're able to show that we can enhance the crunchiness, the crispness and the freshness, and hence the liking of those potato chips by about 15% simply by enhancing the sound of the crunch. We never thought anything of it at the time, just published it in some obscure journal, but then it sort of got picked up by the Ignaubel committee as, you know, why on earth would anybody study that?
麦克风。每当他们咬下一片薯片时，我们就通过麦克风捕捉声音，带到外面，进行一点转换，调大或调小，增强或抑制咀嚼声中的高频部分，然后通过耳机回放。我们能够证明，仅仅通过增强咀嚼的声音，我们就能将这些薯片的酥脆感、新鲜感以及喜爱程度提高约 15%。当时我们没觉得有什么，只是发表在了一本晦涩的期刊上，但后来它被搞笑诺贝尔奖委员会选中了，他们觉得：天哪，为什么会有人研究这个？
Maybe I should get a second Ignable, because I'm still studying it 25 years later, and that illustrates for us kind of the example of sound as a forgotten flavour sense, there the sound of the crunch, the sound of the food itself, but really, it turns out there is a mystery as a title of one article in science in 2000 from Weiss put it, why does nobody like a soggy chip or potato chip or crisp, as we call them? It's got the fat, it's got the flavorings, it's got the salt. The only thing it doesn't have is the crunch, but crunch noise in food has no nutritional value. So why are so many of our snack foods, crispy, crunchy, crackly, snap, and pop is sort of a mystery. And from there, we've been looking both at the sounds of freshness.
也许我应该再拿一个搞笑诺贝尔奖，因为 25 年后我还在研究它。这向我们展示了声音作为一种被遗忘的“风味感官”的例子，即咀嚼的声音、食物本身的声音。但实际上，正如 2000 年《科学》杂志上一篇文章的标题所言，为什么没人喜欢受潮的薯片？它有脂肪，有调味料，有盐。它唯一缺少的就是酥脆感。但食物中的咀嚼声并没有营养价值。所以为什么我们这么多的零食都是酥脆、嘎吱、咔嚓、爆裂的，这真是一个谜。从那时起，我们一直在研究新鲜感的声音。
Maybe in fresh produce, like apples and celery and carrots, allowed a snap or crunch when you bite in, signals of fresher produce, which indicates greater preserve nutrient density from a fresher product. Maybe in the fried and baked category, the biscuits, the crisps, the breakfast cereals, maybe the sound of the crunch. Maybe it indicates fat content, I wonder, because maybe we don't have fat receptors as such in our mouths, but fat something our brain loves for all the energy. So maybe it's a sound of crunch that we've learned probably means it's a fatty food, energy dense, and hence we like the sound. It's not just the food itself. You have found that even the plates and the cutlery we eat with can affect how we experience food. What are the factors
也许在新鲜农产品中，比如苹果、芹菜和胡萝卜，咬下去时响亮的咔嚓声或脆响，是新鲜农产品的信号，这表明新鲜产品中保留了更高的营养密度。也许在油炸和烘焙类别中，饼干、薯片、早餐麦片，也许咀嚼的声音表明了脂肪含量，我很好奇，因为也许我们的口腔中没有专门的脂肪受体，但脂肪是大脑因其能量而喜爱的东西。所以也许咀嚼的声音是我们学会的，它可能意味着这是一种高脂肪、高能量密度的食物，因此我们喜欢这种声音。不仅仅是食物本身。您发现即使是我们用来进食的盘子和餐具也会影响我们对食物的体验。有哪些因素
that go into that? Yeah, so I guess my food research, I wasn't initially interested in studying food because that's, I was interested in the senses and I would be doing lots of warning signals, work on cars and interface design and food and flavor was just what kind of what food scientists did, not what psychologists did in my mind and many others. And I got sort of dragged into
导致了这一点？是的，我想我的食物研究，最初我并不是对研究食物感兴趣，因为我感兴趣的是感官，我当时在做很多关于汽车警告信号和界面设计的工作。在我看来，食物和风味是食品科学家做的事情，而不是心理学家做的事情。我被拖进了
food through Unilever who were funding the lab at the time. And that led into the sonic chip. And from there we sort of started moving out thinking about not just what sound does food make, but also what does it look like? Changing the colour of fruit teas, say, in order to set people's expectations for flavour.
食物领域是通过当时资助实验室的联合利华。这引出了“声音薯片”。从那里开始，我们开始思考，食物不仅发出什么声音，它看起来怎么样？改变水果茶的颜色，比如说，是为了设定人们对风味的预期。
If you see a very bright-colored tea, you'd expect it's going to have an intense flavor. A lot of the products on the market 20 years ago didn't. They looked great. They smelled great. But when you tasted them, they were kind of a bit thin because they didn't have enough sugar in them, as it turns out. So looking at the taste, the texture, the pungency, the sound of food, all stuff within the food itself and how the senses interacted there. And as the years have gone on, we've kind of moved out to think about the sound of the packaging, the color of the packaging. Does that affect the taste?
如果你看到一种颜色非常鲜艳的茶，你会期望它有一种浓郁的风味。20 年前市场上的许多产品并没有做到这一点。它们看起来很棒。闻起来很棒。但当你品尝它们时，它们有点淡，因为事实证明它们含糖量不够。所以观察食物的味道、质地、刺激性、声音，所有这些都是食物本身的东西，以及感官是如何在那里互动的。随着时间的推移，我们开始思考包装的声音、包装的颜色。这会影响味道吗？
Yes, it does, just as much as the, or maybe almost as much as. the colour of the food or drink itself. And then again, to the environments in which we eat and drink, thinking about the colour, the lighting levels, the background music or soundscapes. And they're showing that all of these things, they're not part of the flavour of food or taste. And yet, nevertheless, they can systematically influence the taste. So, for example, we did an experiment with about 3,000 people, maybe one of the world's biggest wine tasting experiments in London in 2014. And over four days, we invited these 3,000 people in. part of the food festival, gave them all a glass of red wine and a black tasting glass so they
是的，它确实会，就像，或者几乎和食物或饮料本身的颜色一样。然后再次回到我们吃喝的环境，思考颜色、照明水平、背景音乐或音景。研究表明，所有这些东西，它们不是食物风味或味道的一部分。然而，它们却能系统地影响味道。例如，我们在 2014 年的伦敦进行了一项涉及约 3000 人的实验，这可能是世界上规模最大的葡萄酒品鉴实验之一。在四天的时间里，我们邀请了这 3000 人。作为美食节的一部分，给他们每人一杯红酒和一个黑色品酒杯，这样他们
couldn't see it, got them to rate the fruitiness, the freshness of the wine, how much they liked it or not. Under white lighting, then we flipped the light switch, turned the room lights to red, asked them to write the wine again, then flipped the room lights to green, rated the same wine in the hand again, and then put the lights back to red, but with some sweet music, some sweet sonic seasoning in the background and the rate of the wine a fourth time. And amazingly, simply by changing the color of the walls, we're able to bring out the fruitiness of the wine by putting the red lights on by about 15%. Turn the lights to green, they bring out the fresh acidic notes in the wine, and then add
就看不见酒的颜色。让他们在白光下评价葡萄酒的果味、新鲜度，以及他们有多喜欢它。然后我们拨动开关，将房间灯光调成红色，让他们再次评价葡萄酒，然后将房间灯光调成绿色，再次评价手中的同一款酒，最后把灯光调回红色，但在背景中加入一些甜美的音乐，一些甜美的“声音调味”，并第四次评价葡萄酒。令人惊讶的是，仅仅通过改变墙壁的颜色，我们就能通过打开红灯将葡萄酒的果味提升约 15%。将灯光调成绿色，它们会带出葡萄酒中新鲜的酸味，然后加入
some sweet or sour sonic seasoning, which sort of makes no sense at all. Why would room color lighting? Why would music sonically season change the taste of the food? It's not part of the food. And yet, surprisingly, it doesn't. I'm still getting to the bottom of it. I remember in 2008, we did the sonic chip, and at the round of the time, I got introduced to a chef called Heston Blumenthal.
一些甜味或酸味的声音调味，这听起来完全没道理。为什么房间的颜色、灯光？为什么音乐这种声音调味会改变食物的味道？它不是食物的一部分。然而，令人惊讶的是，它确实做到了。我还在研究其中的原因。我记得在 2008 年，我们做了声音薯片，当时我被介绍给了一位名叫赫斯顿·布鲁门撒尔的厨师。
We put him in our booth, gave him some Pringles. He came out a changed man saying, you know, wow, sound is the forgotten flavour sense. Sounds an ingredient that can use in the kitchen. And that led into a dish that was then served in the restaurant, in the world's best restaurant as the signature dish, the sound of the seafood dish that comes to the table, looking like the seashore with sand and sashimi, foam, seaweed laid out. but the waiter brings a conch shell out of which dribble some earbuds
我们把他带进我们的展位，给了他一些品客薯片。他出来时变成了一个不同的人，说：“哇，声音是被遗忘的风味感官。声音是一种可以在厨房里使用的配料。”这引出了一道后来在世界上最好的餐厅作为招牌菜供应的菜肴，“海洋之声”。这道菜上桌时，看起来像海边，有沙子、生鱼片、泡沫、海藻。但服务员拿出一个海螺，里面滴出一些耳塞，
and recommends that the diner put those earbuds in, whereupon the diner hears the sounds of the sea, the seagulls, the waves gently crashing on the breach. But that was sort of built on research we did together with the chef to show that these seaside sounds do make seafood taste better, but no more salty. And the sort of chef has creatively taken that insight and then turned it into a dish
并建议食客戴上那些耳塞，随后食客听到了大海的声音、海鸥声、海浪轻轻拍打沙滩的声音。但这建立在我们与厨师共同研究的基础上，证明这些海边的声音确实让海鲜尝起来更美味，但并没有更咸。这位厨师创造性地采纳了这个见解，并将其变成了一道菜，
that has since been sort of replicated around the world and hopefully gets diners coming out of the restaurant if they're lucky enough to go thinking for the first time, Yeah, sound is important. And I never thought about that before and has this amazing effect that for some number of journalists who write about going to the restaurant, and even for people who are lucky enough to get their 50th birthday party for a once-in-a-lifetime meal, they come away and they say, I cried. You work with a chef who had this meal.
这道菜此后在世界各地被复制，并希望让食客在离开餐厅时，如果他们足够幸运的话，第一次想到：“是的，声音很重要。我以前从未想过这一点。”它产生了这种惊人的效果，对于一些写过去那家餐厅的记者，甚至对于那些有幸去那里庆祝 50 岁生日、享用一生一次大餐的人来说，他们离开时说：“我哭了。”您与一位吃过这顿饭的厨师合作。
I think he was in a restaurant in Milan. And we're talking about making people cry. I mean, when you got to the, it was a multi-course meal, right? When you got to the sixth item, which was rice pudding, how can rice pudding? How can rice pudding make people cry? I mean, what was it about that particular dish, the way that it was all put together? Have you looked at it? Yeah, yeah.
我想他是在米兰的一家餐厅。我们谈论的是让人哭泣。我的意思是，当您吃到第六道菜时，那是米饭布丁，米饭布丁怎么能让人哭呢？我的意思是，那道特定的菜，它组合在一起的方式有什么特别之处？您研究过吗？是的，是的。
So, going back to this sort of sound of the sea dish that came onto the menu in the world's best restaurant in 2007, we had no idea it would make anybody cry. But as the newspaper reports came in about this dish and we saw it was happening, I mean, sort of collecting examples of these sort of extraordinary responses to food, dishes that make people cry or that are awe-inspiring or magical or, or give you an ASMR tingle, one of those next shivers you get when people whisper at wrinkle paper. And just by chance, I got introduced to Federico, the chef in Milan,
所以，回到 2007 年在世界上最好的餐厅菜单上出现的“海洋之声”那道菜，我们根本不知道它会让任何人哭。但随着关于这道菜的报纸报道传进来，我们看到它正在发生，我的意思是，收集这些对食物的非凡反应的例子，那些让人哭泣、令人敬畏、神奇，或者给你带来 ASMR 刺痛感（当人们耳语或揉皱纸张时你得到的那些颈部颤栗）的菜肴。偶然间，我被介绍给了米兰的厨师费德里科，
he's a restaurant censorium. He's a young chef every year. He comes out with a new menu, sort of ten courses thereabouts, and you all sit at a counter in front of the chef. And for this ayahuasca-themed menu, kind of all those sort of mystical drugs of the Amazon without the drugs, was this concept.
他的餐厅叫“感官餐厅”。他是一位年轻的厨师，每年都会推出一份新菜单，大约十道菜，你们都坐在厨师面前的柜台旁。对于这份以“死藤水”为主题的菜单，那种亚马逊神秘药物的概念，但没有药物。
And of course number six, as you say, when he started serving this ayahuasca themed menu, people started crying. And it was not what he thought intended either. It just sort of happened, and they never cried for any of his previous menus. Don't cry on the first course or any other courses on this menu. It was only course number six, the rice pudding dish.
当然，正如您所说，第六道菜，当他开始供应这份以“死藤水”为主题的菜单时，人们开始哭泣。这也不是他预想到的。它只是发生了，他们以前的任何菜单都没有让人哭过。第一道菜或其他任何菜都不会哭。只有第六道菜，米饭布丁。
And when I got to hear about that, I was lucky to get to eat at his restaurant, experience a thing for myself. I didn't cry, have to say. And then we got talking to the chef and have been able to do experiments in his restaurant with his diners on that dish to figure out what's going on.
当我听说这件事时，我很幸运能去他的餐厅，亲自体验了一下。我没哭，必须得说。然后我们和厨师交谈，并能够在他的餐厅里用他的食客对那道菜进行实验，以弄清楚发生了什么。
I think nobody cries in a restaurant when you first walk in the door. You need to relax and feel comfortable in the space. So it's probably that this course, six out of ten is important. You're relaxed by this point. And the chef kind of creates an emotional journey because it's like two and a half hours, three hour meal. So a bit like, I know, a movie. And you have all these emotional trajectories of storytelling. And this menu is on the kind of Cinderella thing he describes.
我想没人会在刚进门时就在餐厅里哭。你需要放松并对空间感到舒适。所以这道菜，十道菜里的第六道，可能很重要。到这个时候你已经放松了。厨师创造了一种情感之旅，因为这是一顿两个半小时、三个小时的饭。所以有点像，我知道，一部电影。你拥有所有这些讲故事的情感轨迹。这份菜单是他描述的那种“灰姑娘”式的东西。
Things get good. And then they drop down to really bad and chaotic. And it's just after that really bad moment, that's when this rice pudding occurs. So on this emotional trajectory, once you're relaxed, that's when it happens. And the dish comes to the table as rice pudding. The waiter, waitress will break like a wafer over the top of the bowl for you. So I wonder whether that's kind of a Eucharist sort of religious rituals going on there, maybe. And as well, there are sounds, there's some music, and there's like a nostalgic sounds.
事情变得很好。然后它们跌落到非常糟糕和混乱的状态。就在那个非常糟糕的时刻之后，米饭布丁出现了。所以在这个情感轨迹上，一旦你放松了，事情就会发生。这道菜作为米饭布丁上桌。服务员会像在碗上敲碎威化饼一样为你服务。所以我怀疑那里是否有一种圣餐式的宗教仪式在进行，也许吧。而且，还有声音，有一些音乐，还有一些怀旧的声音。
There's an old man recounting his life from one loud speaker. There's a woman on the other corner like a schoolmistress with little children running around in a school bell. and then at the same time there are also some very low frequency vibrations like sub-audible nought to 20 hertz sound waves but you can't hear them but they make your body feel something like kind of tingle almost you're aware of your body for more than normally the case and so with the chef we've been giving a hundred people the full experience asking them whether they cried or felt like crying did those who cried rate the food as tasting better it's kind of important which they did. And then another 100
一个扬声器里有一个老人在讲述他的一生。另一个角落里有一个像女校长一样的女人，有小孩子在跑来跑去，还有学校的铃声。与此同时，还有一些非常低频的振动，比如亚听觉的 0 到 20 赫兹声波，你听不到它们，但它们让你的身体感觉到某种刺痛感，你比平时更意识到自己的身体。所以，我们和厨师一起，让 100 个人体验了完整的体验，询问他们是否哭了或想哭，那些哭的人是否认为食物更好吃？这很重要，他们确实觉得更好吃。然后另外 100 名
diners without those low frequency vibrations that make you aware of your body. And then 100 delivery drivers who rock up with this week's tomatoes. So would you try some rice pudding? Yes. Did you feel like crying? What are you talking about? I have no idea. That'd be stupid. So none of the
没有那些让你意识到身体的低频振动的食客。还有 100 名送货司机，他们送来了这周的西红柿。那么，你要尝尝米饭布丁吗？是的。你想哭吗？你在说什么？我不知道。那太蠢了。所以没有一个
delivery drivers cried. It's not just about the rice pudding itself. It's something about the whole kind of gestalt of the experience and that when we turn those bodily vibrations off the ultra-low frequency sound. out vibrations, then the rate of crying drops significantly, suggesting that's kind of a part. So we think it's probably these vibrations make you aware of your body. And when you're aware
送货司机哭了。这不仅仅是关于米饭布丁本身。这是关于整个体验的格式塔，当我们关闭那些身体振动，即超低频声音振动时，哭泣率显著下降，这表明这是一种因素。所以我们认为这很可能是这些振动让你意识到自己的身体。当你意识到
of your body's sensations and you're in this sort of nostalgic, emotional frame, then it all kind of comes together. And yeah, just the tears start flowing for, you know, two thirds of diners. That's amazing. But that's the kind of thing where you can only do it in the real world, right? I mean, you can't really recreate something like that in a laboratory. Absolutely. And it's kind of one of the funny things that these days, as psychologists, we always have to fill out endless ethics forms before we undertake research. And, you know, if my ethics panel got to hear that my subjects cried,
身体的感觉，并且处于这种怀旧、情感的框架中时，一切就融合在一起了。是的，眼泪就开始流下来了，对于三分之二的食客来说。太神奇了。但这正是那种只能在现实世界中做的事情，对吧？我的意思是，你不能在实验室里真正重现这样的事情。绝对是这样。而且这很有趣，如今作为心理学家，我们在进行研究之前总是必须填写无休止的伦理表格。而且，如果我的伦理委员会听说我的受试者哭了，
my participants, sorry, these days, cried, I'd be in big trouble. Right. I'll be hauled up. What on earth are you doing? How dare you do that? It's not ethically justified. Whereas the creatives, I think, I know artists, but also the chefs, mixologists, they're both perhaps more capable of eliciting these extreme strong emotions and then
我的参与者，抱歉，这些天哭了，我会遇到大麻烦。对。我会受到传唤。你到底在做什么？你怎么敢那样做？这在伦理上是不合理的。而创意人员，我想，我知道艺术家，还有厨师、调酒师，他们可能更有能力引发这些极端强烈的情绪，然后
dealing with the consequences. They have the tissues on hand. And so, yeah, this is the sort of thing that works much better there. And you probably couldn't recreate in the lab. And I sort of remember when we were doing the Sound of the Sea experiments, the chef came up to Oxford to the Science Museum here, and we had 150 people for a conference. They'd pay some money. They wanted some food. He brought up a van of oysters. We did the sound of the sea versus the sound of farmyard chickens. Showed that the sea sounds like things better. And then he also brought up some bacon and egg ice cream,
处理后果。他们手边有纸巾。所以，是的，这是在那种环境下效果更好的事情。你可能无法在实验室里重现。我记得我们在做“海洋之声”实验时，厨师来到牛津的科学博物馆，我们有 150 人参加会议。他们付了一些钱。他们想要一些食物。他带了一辆装满牡蛎的货车。我们做了海洋的声音与农场鸡的声音的对比。证明了海洋的声音让东西更好吃。然后他还带了一些培根和鸡蛋冰淇淋，
which was a dish in the restaurant at the time. A very strange bacon and egg in an ice cream. It's kind of all kinds of wrong, that sort of molecular and modernist. Gave people that to eat while they heard the sounds of sizzling bacon or the farmyard chickens. We could flip the flavor. And then that's sort of great. The dish works very well in the restaurant. But then we had some more batches of the bacon and our ice cream
那是当时餐厅里的一道菜。一种非常奇怪的培根和鸡蛋冰淇淋。那种分子和现代主义的东西有点不对劲。让人们在听到滋滋作响的培根声或农场鸡的声音时吃那个。我们可以改变风味。这很好，这道菜在餐厅里效果很好。但后来我们还有更多的培根和鸡蛋冰淇淋批次
that I would give to participants. in the lab for some follow-up carefully controlled studies. And there, people go, oh, that's horrible. In their own context, it's like, that's just really nasty ice cream. If you know, it's like a designed experience from the creative chef or in a design shop, then you're much happier to, you may even expect to be surprised or confronted by sensory incongerancy. So there it works, but only there can you study it.
我会在实验室里给参与者进行后续仔细控制的研究。在那里，人们会说，哦，那太可怕了。在他们自己的背景下，就像，那只是非常糟糕的冰淇淋。如果你知道，这是一种来自创意厨师的设计体验，或者在设计店里，那么你更乐意，你甚至可能期待被感官的不协调所惊讶或面对。所以它在那里有效，但只有在那里你才能研究它。
And things like, you know, surprise when you bite into something that looks like a, an apple that tastes like a pineapple or that you can only do once. And again, that's very hard to capture in a lab situation when somebody comes in a white coat and gets you to fill in the consent form and is monitoring you and the whole atmosphere is not conducive to maybe that more, how should you put it, emotional or engaged response or something. A few years back, we, on speaking of psychology, did an episode on synesthesia in which the researcher, Dr. Julius Simner, talked about how people with synesthesia can taste certain words, which can even taste nasty. She said she had one subject
还有一些事情，比如，当你咬下一口看起来像苹果但尝起来像菠萝的东西时的惊喜，你只能做一次。同样，当有人穿着白大褂让你填写知情同意书并监控你时，在实验室情况下很难捕捉到这一点，整个氛围不利于那种，你应该怎么说，情感或参与的反应。几年前，我们在《心理学谈话》中做了一期关于联觉的节目，研究员朱莉娅·辛纳博士谈到了联觉者如何能品尝某些词语，甚至尝起来很恶心。她说她有一个受试者
who thought her name was nasty, and so he wouldn't even say it. So how is what you studied different from synesthesia? So there are all these things like the crunch of the crisp, and it's all kind of part of the thing itself. That's sort of maybe multi-sensory. And then there are these more surprising connections between the senses, such as, you know, when I ask you to think, what's the sweetest color? Most people will say, pinkish red or something. If I ask you to say,
认为她的名字很恶心，所以他甚至不会说出来。那么您研究的内容与联觉有什么不同？所以有所有这些东西，比如薯片的嘎吱声，它都是事物本身的一部分。那可能是多感官的。然后感官之间还有这些更令人惊讶的联系，比如，当我让你思考，最甜的颜色是什么？大多数人会说是粉红色或类似的东西。如果我让你说，
is sweetness round or angular? People think it's going to be sweet. It's round. Bitterness is angular. And these are like these surprising connections between the senses. And that's a bit like synesthesia, but I think they're fundamentally different
甜味是圆的还是有棱角的？人们认为它会是甜的。它是圆的。苦味是有棱角的。这些就像感官之间令人惊讶的联系。这有点像联觉，但我认为它们有根本的不同。
and Jules, who I was an undergraduate with here in Oxford back in the 80s. Yeah, we have debates about this. I think synesthesia's for a long time played a really important role in stimulating artists, creatives, Nabokov, Kandinsky, Scriabin, you name it. But the synesthetic connections are kind of unusual. They're idiosyncratic. You know, one synesthetic experience is blue for Monday. The next synethite says, no, it's orangey,
朱尔斯，我和她是 80 年代在牛津的本科同学。是的，我们对此有争论。我认为联觉长期以来在激发艺术家、创意人员方面发挥了非常重要的作用，纳博科夫、康定斯基、斯克里亚宾，等等。但联觉联系有点不寻常。它们是特质的。你知道，一种联觉体验是周一是蓝色的。下一个联觉者说，不，它是橙色的，
gold. And so the connections are different. Whereas what I'm studying is this kind of universal synesthesia, which I call cross-modal correspondences, these surprising connections between the senses that we share between tastes and colors and shapes and textures and sounds and tombrers and tempos and rhythms and roughness. Very surprising, but really interesting. And so far in our research, after we did the Sound of the Sea experiment that led into the dish, we'd never have done that study if there hadn't been 150 people turning up the next day and they demanded some food. We didn't think of what to do. It'd be too crazy to think that playing seaside sounds would change the taste of, after a few years of the dish being on the menu, people started saying,
金色的。所以联系是不同的。而我正在研究的是这种“普遍联觉”，我称之为“跨模态对应”，这些我们在味觉、颜色、形状、质地、声音、音色、节奏和粗糙度之间共享的感官之间令人惊讶的联系。非常令人惊讶，但真的很有趣。到目前为止，在我们的研究中，在我们做了导致那道菜的“海洋之声”实验后，如果第二天没有 150 人出现并要求提供食物，我们永远不会做那项研究。我们没想过要做什么。认为播放海边的声音会改变味道太疯狂了，在菜品出现在菜单上几年后，人们开始说，
Well, it's obvious, isn't it? Seaside sounds, make fish and chips taste better by the seaside. We didn't need your psychologist to tell us that. Right. So we have to try and think of the next new thing. And that became this sort of sonic seasoning, narrowly defined, which is when we use music to change taste of food. Because if we know that sweet tastes are more high pitch,
“嗯，这很明显，不是吗？海边的声音让海边的炸鱼薯条更好吃。我们不需要你的心理学家来告诉我们。”对。所以我们必须尝试思考下一个新事物。这就是狭义上的“声音调味”，即当我们使用音乐来改变食物的味道时。因为如果我们知道甜味更偏向高音，
more like to be piano sounds, bitter tastes, the lower the pitch of the music or sound, the more bitter. Brassy sounds are bitter. And now we have these whole musical menus for bitter, spicy, creamy, sweet, salty, umami of exactly what the music or soundscape should have in terms of tempo, rhythm, and so on. And then we can either find music off the shelf that has those qualities, or get a composer or sound designer to create composition to match, accentuate the taste. And this is, yeah, often described as synesthesia.
更像是钢琴声，苦味，音乐或声音的音调越低，就越苦。铜管乐器的声音是苦的。现在我们有这些完整的音乐菜单，针对苦、辣、奶油、甜、咸、鲜，关于音乐或音景在节奏、韵律等方面应该具备什么。然后我们可以找到现成的具有这些品质的音乐，或者让作曲家或声音设计师创作作品来匹配、强调味道。这通常被描述为联觉。
Certainly back in the 1930s, the Italian futurists, people like F.T. Maranetti, He's got a whole futurist cookbook where you find most of modernist cuisine in an idea, if not in execution, and probably a horrible man, sort of misogynist, and all sorts of bad things.
当然，早在 20 世纪 30 年代，意大利未来主义者，像 F.T. 马里内蒂这样的人，他有一整本未来主义食谱，你在其中可以找到大多数现代主义烹饪的想法，如果不是在执行中，而且可能是一个糟糕的人，某种厌女症，以及各种坏事。
But in the futurist cookbook, there are all sorts of great ideas and he talks about syntactylismo, sin-auditivo, synesthetic sound, synesthetic touch. They thought it was synesthesia then. I think they were wrong about that, but they were right that textures and tastes correspond. We can study them in the lab
但在未来主义食谱中，有各种各样的好主意，他谈到了“触觉主义”、“听觉主义”、联觉声音、联觉触觉。他们当时认为那是联觉。我认为他们错了，但他们是对的，质地和味道是对应的。我们可以在实验室里研究它们，
and then work with Chocolate tiers, wine brands, coffee, designers, plateware manufacturers, such that we can hear by changing the text on your coffee cup, to be rougher or smoother, we can then change your experience of the body of the coffee, which could be a good thing or a bad thing, depending on the brew you're drinking and what kind of taste world you live in. So do you do dinner parties where you curate the music to go along with what you're serving? Absolutely, of course. Certainly we do. I have to contend with Mrs. Spence. So a lot of my ideas about astrophysics. I'm not allowed. All my black angular plates. I've got a very good scientific
然后与巧克力商、葡萄酒品牌、咖啡、设计师、餐具制造商合作，这样我们就可以通过改变咖啡杯上的文字，使其更粗糙或更光滑，从而改变你对咖啡主体的体验，这可能是一件好事或坏事，取决于你喝的咖啡和你生活在什么样的味道世界中。那么您会举办晚宴，策划音乐来搭配您供应的食物吗？当然，当然。我们当然会。我必须与斯彭斯夫人抗衡。所以我关于美食物理学的很多想法。我不被允许。我所有的黑色有棱角的盘子。我有一个非常好的科学
reason why they work for certain foods, but she doesn't like them, so they're out on the street. A few things stick, though, but once a month she will let us have like a multi-sensory lab dinner party, and then we all get to have some fun. We've had some chefs in residence over the years, and they would cook away. I remember one memorable occasion where we had a Rupert Ponsonby, who does beer marketing. He brought a whole range of beers, and then we had my my wife's ironing table, all the beers arranged on top and a tone generator. And we sort of recreated Holt Hanson's 1969 pitch of harmony experiment when he brought people into Copenhagen University,
理由说明它们为什么对某些食物有效，但她不喜欢它们，所以它们被扔到街上了。不过，有几样东西留下来了，但每个月她都会让我们举办一次多感官实验室晚宴，然后我们大家都能玩得很开心。这些年来我们有一些驻场厨师，他们会做饭。我记得有一次令人难忘的场合，我们有鲁珀特·庞森比，他做啤酒营销。他带来了一整套啤酒，然后我们有我妻子的熨衣板，所有的啤酒都摆在上面，还有一个音调发生器。我们重现了霍尔特·汉森 1969 年的“和谐音调”实验，当时他把人们带到哥本哈根大学，
gave them Carlsberg regular lager and Carlsberg elephant export lager that's stronger. And so just twiddle with the tone on the tone generator to you find the frequency that matches the taste. People think it's bizarre. But then with 10 people and sort of 10 bottles of beer, you find that people match the stronger, more alcoholic export lager to a higher-pitched sound. And so we sort of recreated that. And again, he in 1960s and 70s was showing that when you played the pitch of harmony to people
给了他们嘉士伯普通拉格啤酒和嘉士伯大象出口拉格啤酒，那种更浓的。所以只是拨动音调发生器上的音调，直到你找到与味道匹配的频率。人们认为这很离奇。但后来有 10 个人和 10 瓶啤酒，你发现人们将更浓、酒精含量更高的出口拉格啤酒与更高音调的声音匹配起来。所以我们重现了那个实验。而且他在 20 世纪 60 年代和 70 年代也展示了，当你播放和谐音调给人们听时，
as they tasted the matching beer, then they had, you know, these sort of experiences where the hands were shaking, their heads were expanding, the kind of research that I guess made psychologists not ask their participants what they thought anymore. Just filling the question, you know, just give me a one to ten answer. I want to hear from you, whereas in the old days, you'd ask people, you know, how was it for you? As a subject, what went on and you got all these weird responses. And I, ever since I first came across that study in the library, when I was an undergraduate, I wanted to reproduce it, and we had it there in the lab dinner while the chef was cutting
当他们品尝匹配的啤酒时，他们有这些体验，手在颤抖，头在膨胀，这种研究我想让心理学家不再问参与者他们的想法了。只是填问卷，给我一个 1 到 10 的答案。我想听听你的意见，而在过去，你会问人们，这对你来说怎么样？作为受试者，发生了什么，你得到了所有这些奇怪的反应。自从我还是本科生在图书馆里第一次看到那个研究以来，我就想重现它，我们在实验室晚宴上做到了，当时厨师正在把
potatoes into 3D sculptures, just like Maranetti was doing in the 1930s. I know it's turning my wife's, Christoff, very expensive silver cutlery, and he'd been to the market at the chef and he bought, I'm not sure, a bunch of hairs with their pelts and they wrapped the skin and the hair of the pelt of the hairs around my wife's cutlery and then we had served a hair stew and anybody who's there will still remember it that you're sort of feeling the animal, the warmth of the fur in your hand of their spoon, you could smell the animal and you're eating and it sort of makes you much more mindful about what you're eating and it is kind of a in tactileism, most kind of touch and taste coming together, just like in those futurist dinner
土豆切成 3D 雕塑，就像马里内蒂在 20 世纪 30 年代所做的那样。我知道这正在把我的妻子的、非常昂贵的银餐具，他去过市场，厨师买了一堆野兔，带着它们的皮毛，他们把野兔的皮和毛包裹在我妻子的餐具上，然后我们供应了野兔炖肉，任何在那里的人都会记得，你感觉到动物，勺子上皮毛的温暖，你可以闻到动物的味道，你在吃，这让你对你正在吃的东西更加正念，这是一种触觉主义，触觉和味觉结合在一起，就像在那些未来主义晚宴中一样。
parties. And yeah, lots of fun was had by all and amazing how many, that's just like a chance to play really and to see what works and some of the dishes that have been served in those multi-sensory lab dinners, then end up being kind of formal research that we follow up in the lab with larger sample sizes who are blinded to the purpose of the research and so on and so forth. We're going to take a short break. When we return, I'll talk with Dr. Starr's, about how distracted eating changes our experience of food and about what makes food trends go viral. Hey, y'all. It's Kelly Clarkson with Wayfair. Ever order furniture online and wonder, what if? Like, what if it doesn't hold up? That sofa was four days old. You should have ordered from Wayfair.
是的，大家玩得很开心，令人惊讶的是，这只是一个真正玩耍的机会，看看什么有效，在那些多感官实验室晚宴中供应的一些菜肴，后来变成了正式的研究，我们在实验室里用更大的样本量进行后续研究，他们对研究的目的不知情，等等。我们要休息一下。回来后，我将与斯塔斯博士谈谈分心进食如何改变我们的食物体验，以及是什么让食物趋势变得病毒式传播。嘿，大家好。我是凯莉·克拉克森，与 Wayfair 合作。有没有在网上订购过家具并想过，“如果……会怎样？”比如，如果它不耐用怎么办？那张沙发才用了四天。你应该从 Wayfair 订购。
With Wayfair, there's no what if. Just style you love and quality you can trust. Visit Wayfair.com. Wayfair, every style, every home. I want to ask you a lot of us, particularly in the States, maybe you do this in England as well, A lot of us eat in front of the TV. What is the impact of eating in front of the TV on how you experience your food? Mostly bad, bad, bad from the gastrophysics book. That was one of the strongest relations that came out. Some research showing that we eat significantly more when distracted by technology.
有了 Wayfair，就没有“如果”。只有你喜欢的风格和你可以信赖的质量。访问 Wayfair.com。Wayfair，每种风格，每个家。我想问你，我们很多人，特别是在美国，也许你在英国也这样做，我们很多人在电视前吃饭。在电视前吃饭对你体验食物有什么影响？大部分是坏的，坏的，坏的，来自《美食物理学》这本书。这是出现的最强烈的关系之一。一些研究表明，当被技术分心时，我们吃得明显更多。
Quite how much more. It could be as much as 30% more when eating with the TV on than off. It all depends whether it's a new show or a repeat and how entertainment. the program is as to how much more, but yeah, significantly more with a TV on. And these days, I guess a lot of people will eat with their mobile device instead. And there is something like 10 to 15% increase in consumption. So I think generally very bad, in part because those technologies just distract us from what we're eating. And I think our brain is going to use the sensations associated with consumption
到底多了多少？边看电视边吃饭，摄入量可能会比不看电视时多出30%。这取决于节目是新剧还是重播，以及节目的娱乐性如何，但可以肯定的是，开着电视吃会多吃很多。如今，我想很多人会选择边看手机边吃饭。这会导致摄入量增加约10%到15%。所以我认为这通常非常糟糕，部分原因是这些技术分散了我们对食物的注意力。我认为我们的大脑会利用与进食相关的感官体验
to figure out when we should stop eating. so if all the sensations we get at from the TV or on mobile device we're not aware of the tastes and the textures then it takes more food before our brain says okay I've had enough food sensations it's time to stop now and that's kind of why you end up eating more that's definitely the bad side but I do think there's sort of potential here to turn it for force for good sometimes and so we did a project back in 2017 with one of the
来判断我们何时应该停止进食。因此，如果我们从电视或手机上获取了所有感官刺激，却没能意识到食物的味道和质地，那么大脑就需要更多的食物才能发出“我已经吃饱了，现在该停下来了”的信号。这就是为什么你最终会吃得更多，这绝对是负面影响。但我确实认为，有时也有潜力将其转化为一种积极的力量。我们在2017年曾与一家
home food delivery companies they're the UK and I'm not sure whether it was Netflix or one of the other streaming services. We knew all it was Game of Thrones. It was there was like a mafia TV series at the time and some other shows. And we knew what was going to be airing the next episode. So worked with a chef to make the meals that matched what the characters on the shows you might be watching on the streaming service would be eating. And there I think there could be a possible sort of resonance that you are almost, you know,
外卖公司合作，那是英国的一家公司，我不确定是Netflix还是其他流媒体服务。我们知道那是《权力的游戏》。当时还有一部黑帮题材的电视剧和其他一些节目。我们知道下一集什么时候播出。因此，我们与一位厨师合作，制作了与流媒体服务上正在播放的节目中角色所吃食物相匹配的餐点。我认为这可能会产生一种共鸣，让你几乎，你知道，
by eating the same thing as the characters on screen are eating, then it sort of connects you and maybe rather than distracting you, turns it into a more immersive, engaging, multisensory experience than otherwise would have been the case. So you were recently quoted in an article talking about Dubai chocolate, which is everywhere right now. What is it about Dubai chocolate that, in a multisensory sense, has made it so trendy? I think it's all about the eye appeal, the Instagram ability, not really anything to do with the taste or the texture or the chemicals.
通过吃屏幕上角色正在吃的东西，它会产生一种连接感，也许它不会分散你的注意力，反而将其变成一种比平时更具沉浸感、参与感和多感官的体验。你最近在文章中被引用谈论迪拜巧克力，它现在无处不在。从多感官的角度来看，迪拜巧克力为什么会如此流行？我认为这完全是因为它的视觉吸引力，即“Instagram属性”，与味道、质地或化学成分无关。
You might like it or not. For me, it's too sweet. It's kind of this sort of a chocolate on the outside, maybe it's a gold bar, a bling appeal. And on the inside, I'll have this very bright green kind of pistachio and other stuff, kind of crunchy interior. Didn't exist, you know, sort of five years ago
你可能喜欢也可能不喜欢。对我来说，它太甜了。它外面是一种巧克力，可能像金条一样，有一种炫耀的吸引力。里面则是非常鲜艳的绿色开心果和其他配料，口感很脆。你知道，五年前它根本不存在，
and sort of exploded so that wherever you go now, like in a European capital, you'll see that green and brown imagery for smoothies, for cakes, for hot drinks, for ice creams for chocolate, you name it. So what's going on? I think it's really all about Instagramability in that if I discovered a new regular chocolate bar that was the best tasting chocolate I'd ever had,
然后突然爆发，以至于现在无论你走到哪里，比如在欧洲的首都，你都会看到那种绿色和棕色的形象，无论是冰沙、蛋糕、热饮、冰淇淋还是巧克力，应有尽有。那么发生了什么？我认为这完全是因为它的“Instagram属性”，如果我发现了一种新的普通巧克力棒，那是我吃过最好吃的巧克力，
I couldn't share that with you over Instagram or social media. The picture of it would just look browned like any other chocolate. So it's impossible to kind of communicate visually, digitally, deliciousness, whereas the Dubai chocolate has this distinctively different eye appeal, the green and brown. That color combination doesn't really exist in anything else. And hence when I see it, I can uniquely index that food.
我无法通过Instagram或社交媒体与你分享。它的照片看起来就像任何其他棕色的巧克力一样。因此，在视觉和数字层面上，很难传达出它的美味，而迪拜巧克力具有独特的视觉吸引力，即绿色和棕色。这种颜色组合在其他任何东西中都不存在。因此，当我看到它时，我可以独特地识别出这种食物。
And hence it's much more Instagramable. And I think successful, paired with other things like, Aparol Spritz has had a moment in recent years. And Provensal Rose wine has had a resurgence of popularity. And again, for both of those drinks, the idea is they look good on Instagram. or they look distinctively different. If you saw a clear drink, it could be gin and tonic, it could be spright, it could be soda water,
因此，它更适合在Instagram上分享。我认为成功的案例还包括其他事物，比如Aperol Spritz（阿佩罗橙光）近年来非常流行。普罗旺斯桃红葡萄酒也重新流行起来。同样，对于这两种饮料，它们的理念都是在Instagram上看起来很棒，或者看起来与众不同。如果你看到一种透明的饮料，它可能是金汤力，可能是雪碧，也可能是苏打水，
you wouldn't know what it was. But that's kind of orangey of aporol, on a summer's evening, somewhere in a piazza and a Mediterranean, then it can only be one thing. And it's that distinctive difference that helps these products to really become viral. And probably also explains then if you have a product that doesn't look distinctly different, the question of why things like extreme spicy challenges, extreme sour challenges are becoming a thing, And there I think it's why those two tastes? Well, because those are things that I can express through my facial pain
你不会知道它是什么。但在夏日的傍晚，在地中海的广场上，那种橙色的Aperol，它只能是那一种东西。正是这种独特的差异帮助这些产品真正走红。这也可能解释了为什么如果你的产品看起来没有明显的不同，为什么像极辣挑战、极酸挑战这样的东西会流行起来。我认为为什么是这两种味道？嗯，因为这些是我可以通过面部表情表现出来的东西，
or eating a very hot chili food. You will see me sweating and a very sour-faced food will make my face puckered up. And so in a way I can communicate those tastes through the extreme response in my face in a way that I couldn't with sweetness. So it's going to look different or evoke in you, the consumer, some extreme physical response that can then be conveyed through media. and that these things will sort of, I think, are becoming more and more rapidly emerging as sort of AI starts to pick up much more rapidly on emerging food trends around the world, matcha tea or bubble tea or the Dubai chocolate, picking up on the trends more rapidly and allowing food companies to deliver to market their new version of Dubai Chocolate X in time to kind of meet the ascending wave of popularity. whereas in the past, by the time the food company had heard about this new trend,
或者吃非常辣的辣椒食物。你会看到我出汗，而非常酸的食物会让我皱起眉头。所以，在某种程度上，我可以通过面部极端的反应来传达这些味道，而甜味则做不到。所以它看起来会不同，或者在消费者心中唤起某种极端的生理反应，然后可以通过媒体传播。我认为随着人工智能开始更迅速地捕捉全球新兴的食品趋势，这些东西正变得越来越快地涌现，无论是抹茶、珍珠奶茶还是迪拜巧克力，人工智能能更快地捕捉趋势，让食品公司及时推出新版本的迪拜巧克力，以赶上日益增长的流行浪潮。而在过去，当食品公司听说这个新趋势时，
it's kind of too late already to ride the wave. Speaking of AI, you have any thoughts on how and whether AI is going to be, say, designing new dishes or entire cuisines? Yes and no. I think not in a way that so far people have thought about it, which has been a lot of excitement about the idea of sort of flavor pairing, the idea that you could combine ingredients effectively in a dish. if you know what molecules and volatile compounds, chemicals are having them,
已经太晚了，无法赶上这波浪潮。说到人工智能，你对人工智能将如何设计新菜肴或整个菜系有什么看法吗？既有又没有。我认为不是人们目前所想的那种方式，人们对“风味搭配”的概念感到非常兴奋，即如果你知道菜肴中哪些分子、挥发性化合物和化学物质，你就可以有效地组合食材。
and two foods that share similar chemicals, will pair well together. So you get things like caviar and white chocolate share a molecule. Indol and sort of jasmine and pork share a molecule. So they go very well together. cauliflower and dark chocolate. Or maybe it's blue cheese. They go together. So you get some very unusual combinations that work well,
两种含有相似化学成分的食物会搭配得很好。所以你会得到像鱼子酱和白巧克力共享一个分子这样的组合。吲哚、茉莉花和猪肉共享一个分子。所以它们搭配得很好。花椰菜和黑巧克力。或者可能是蓝纹奶酪。它们搭配在一起。所以你会得到一些非常不寻常但效果很好的组合，
and the idea being they share a molecule. And with AI and large language models, that seems to make the whole process of pairing flavors based on shared compounds, much easier than looking up numbers in charts and things. And yet, I think that's not going to work in the end because I don't think flavor pairing is generally a sound principle. And certainly when people have studied it systematically,
其理念是它们共享一个分子。有了人工智能和大语言模型，基于共享化合物进行风味搭配的过程似乎比查阅图表和数字要容易得多。然而，我认为最终这行不通，因为我不认为风味搭配通常是一个合理的原则。当然，当人们系统地研究它时，
foods are not likely to go well together just because they share a compound. But instead, I think the way that AI is already starting, to change the food landscape is with, illustrated by a chef we work with in London called Joseph Husser, and he very often gets invited to make like new foods for a Virgin Galactic over in Arizona when they had a party for the people who put a deposit down being on the space first space tourists. Or when the Willy Wonka movie came to London for his launch with Timothy Chamorlet,
食物仅仅因为共享一种化合物并不意味着它们搭配得好。相反，我认为人工智能已经开始改变食品领域的方式，正如我们在伦敦合作的一位名叫Joseph Husser的厨师所展示的那样，他经常被邀请为亚利桑那州的维珍银河公司制作新食物，当时他们为那些为太空旅行支付定金的首批太空游客举办了派对。或者当《旺卡》电影在伦敦举行首映礼，提莫西·查拉梅出席时，
whatever a year ago, he was asked in both cases, can he make some canapes to match the event? Very often when he makes those things, then the client says, okay, now that's too adventurous. Just give me the cheese and pineapple sticks. And he's wasted all that effort. So what he started doing is really clever, I think, is asking AI to generate the visual concept of a dish. So he types in for the, say, for the Wonka movie, he says, give me a chocolate hairbrush. And then AI comes up with his amazing sort of chocolate, chocolate eclair with hair.
大约一年前，他在这两种情况下都被问到，能否制作一些与活动相匹配的开胃小菜？通常当他制作这些东西时，客户会说，好吧，那太冒险了。就给我奶酪和菠萝棒吧。他所有的努力都白费了。所以他开始做的事情非常聪明，我认为，就是让AI生成菜肴的视觉概念。所以他输入，比如为《旺卡》电影，他说，给我一个巧克力发刷。然后AI就想出了这种令人惊叹的巧克力闪电泡芙，上面有头发。
if the client likes the idea from just on the visual image, then he's got sign off, and then he goes and figures out how to make it and sources from around the world ingredients. So to get the hair on their chocolate declare hairbrush, that was going to Turkey for some Turkish Pisani or something. They have some sort of food stuff that matches. And that's been very successful for him as a kind of aid
如果客户从视觉图像上喜欢这个想法，那么他就获得了批准，然后他再去研究如何制作它，并从世界各地采购食材。为了在巧克力闪电泡芙发刷上做出头发，他去了土耳其寻找某种土耳其开心果之类的东西。他们有一些匹配的食品材料。这对他来说非常成功，作为一种
to culinary creativity rather than a replacement of, that maybe it's really good at sort of generating ideas, but any of those ideas that are generated by AI, given that AI doesn't taste nor smell, have to be then sense-checked by the real creative of the kitchen in order to make sure that they work or otherwise. When we did a study last 24, we got lots of Instagram images of foods, raw foods, processed and ultra-fut processed like carrots, carrot juice and carrot cake. And then we made an AI version of the same foods and asked whether people
烹饪创意的辅助工具，而不是替代品。它可能非常擅长产生想法，但任何由AI生成的想法，考虑到AI既没有味觉也没有嗅觉，必须由厨房里真正的创意人员进行感官检查，以确保它们可行。我们在24年做了一项研究，我们收集了大量食物的Instagram图片，包括生食、加工食品和超加工食品，如胡萝卜、胡萝卜汁和胡萝卜蛋糕。然后我们制作了相同食物的AI版本，并询问人们
could tell the difference. And in 2024, with the software we used, people could say, yep, that's AI generated food image. As such, we don't like it as much as the real thing. But roller clocks forward now and with every evolution of the AI, it gets harder and harder to tell the difference. And more and more tempting for the food companies in the marketing to present AI generated dishes. And the real concern for me is that maybe they will be generated to be ultimately appealing to our brain because, you know, the AI will sort of realize that, you know, if it's the image of the food should be from a first person perspective and look large and have yolk porn, with a protein in motion dribbling out, and it should have lots of energy density because
是否能分辨出区别。在2024年，使用我们使用的软件，人们可以说，是的，这是AI生成的食物图像。因此，我们不像喜欢真实食物那样喜欢它。但随着时间的推移，随着AI的每一次进化，分辨出区别变得越来越难。食品公司在营销中展示AI生成的菜肴也越来越诱人。我真正担心的是，它们可能会被设计成最终吸引我们的大脑，因为你知道，AI会意识到，如果食物的图像应该从第一人称视角拍摄，看起来很大，有蛋黄流出的效果，蛋白质在运动中滴落，并且应该有很高的能量密度，因为
that's what our brains love. And it will create these hyper-delectable food images that even if we do not eat the images that we see, they may nevertheless set the standards for what we think is acceptable in a meal. And that's going to go all the way through to one of my favorite examples from last year or two was a restaurant in Austin, Texas, ethos, I think it was called, the restaurant. And you go online, it's got these amazing images of, like, a croissants in the shape of hippopotamuses that look huge. And then sort of flower arrangements of sushi, amazing. And a restaurant manager who can take your booking for a table called, oh, is it, Giuseppe Fuzilli. And the whole thing's AI generated. There is no restaurant. There is no restaurant manager. He's a
那是我们大脑所喜爱的。它会创造出这些超级诱人的食物图像，即使我们不吃我们看到的图像，它们也可能为我们认为一顿饭可以接受的标准设定了门槛。这甚至会延伸到我去年或前年最喜欢的例子之一，德克萨斯州奥斯汀的一家餐厅，我想它叫Ethos。你上网看，它有令人惊叹的图像，比如看起来巨大的河马形状的牛角面包。还有寿司花艺，太棒了。还有一位可以为你预订座位的餐厅经理，叫，哦，是Giuseppe Fuzilli吗？整个事情都是AI生成的。没有那家餐厅。没有餐厅经理。他是一个
lot and all these food images are but they're sort of so appealing in a generation following. Yeah, yeah, everyone wants to eat there. I know we've all been tricked by one of these sort of digital hallucinations and yeah, it's going to become harder and harder to watch out for them. So just to wrap up, what's next for you? What are you studying now? What are your big questions ahead that you want to answer?
谎言，所有这些食物图像都是，但它们在下一代中非常有吸引力。是的，是的，每个人都想去那里吃。我知道我们都被这些数字幻觉中的一种欺骗了，是的，要提防它们会变得越来越难。那么总结一下，你接下来要做什么？你现在在研究什么？你未来想要回答的重大问题是什么？
All sorts, all sorts of stuff. Maybe one of the big ones is when we've tried over the last decade or two to create these multi-sensory experiences by adding an extra sense, some music or lighting to something or touch. But it's often been just trying to add another sense to kind of match
各种各样的事情。也许其中一个大问题是，在过去的一二十年里，我们试图通过增加一种额外的感官，比如音乐、灯光或触觉，来创造这些多感官体验。但这通常只是试图增加另一种感官来匹配
with what's already there. So we pick a sound that matches the taste. There's congruent with it. But I've recently been looking a lot at the literature on sort of media studies and film music design, an area I haven't come across before, but it's an own separate world. And there to see
已经存在的东西。所以我们选择一种与味道相匹配的声音。它是与之相符的。但我最近一直在大量阅读关于媒体研究和电影音乐设计的文献，这是一个我以前从未接触过的领域，但它是一个独立的世界。在那里可以看到
all the clever ways that sort of movie directors and those who create the compositions for movie scores will use sound sometimes in sort of a counterpoint. Sometimes they'll have, you know, really violent scenes on screen, Quentin Tarantino and Stanley Kubrick, sort of famous examples, where when they have ultraviolence on screen, they might have, you know, singing in the rain or something, happy music as a sort of counterpoint. So could you have a culinary counterpoint? I don't think anyone has tried that yet, having music that deliberately goes against something in the dish and makes sense only as a kind of composite.
电影导演和电影配乐创作者使用声音的所有巧妙方式，有时会使用对位法。有时他们会在屏幕上出现非常暴力的场景，昆汀·塔伦蒂诺和斯坦利·库布里克是著名的例子，当屏幕上出现极端暴力时，他们可能会播放《雨中曲》之类的快乐音乐作为一种对位。那么你能有烹饪对位吗？我认为还没有人尝试过，让音乐故意与菜肴中的某种东西背道而驰，只有作为一种复合体才有意义。
And then these other examples of all these big words I have to look up and I forget now, anathathia or something, where the music starts and then something happens on screen and then the music keeps continuing. It's like the music's doesn't care about the world, doesn't care about what's going on, it continues regardless of these terrible things.
还有其他一些例子，所有这些我必须查阅的大词，我现在忘了，比如“anatheia”之类的，音乐开始播放，然后屏幕上发生了一些事情，然后音乐继续播放。就像音乐不在乎这个世界，不在乎发生了什么，它不顾这些可怕的事情继续播放。
And again, it could use that sort of notion in the dining concept and what would it mean I think there are lots of these ideas from this kind of mood music in film to think could we translate that into a multi-sensory dining experience to create new kinds of things where we don't just match what's already there that do something different, something that augments it, and that maybe ultimately we can sort of deliver this kind of idea of a multi-sensory gestalt or the total work of art being very ambitious,
同样，可以在餐饮概念中使用这种概念，这意味着什么？我认为从电影中的这种情绪音乐中有很多想法，可以思考我们是否能将其转化为多感官餐饮体验，创造出新的东西，我们不仅仅是匹配已经存在的东西，而是做一些不同的事情，一些增强它的东西，也许最终我们可以实现这种多感官格式塔或整体艺术作品的想法，这非常有野心，
that does sort of engage all of the senses and only make sense when all the senses kind of come together we'll see if we ever get there. But a worthy challenge that will keep me going for a good few years yet, I should say. Well, I want to thank you, Dr. Spence, for joining me today. This has been just amazing, and now I'm hungry, and I have to go find something to eat. Thank you. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at speakingofpsychology.org or on Apple, Spotify, YouTube, or wherever you get your podcasts.
它确实调动了所有的感官，只有当所有感官结合在一起时才有意义。我们将看看我们是否能达到那个目标。但我应该说，这是一个值得挑战的目标，它将让我再忙上几年。好吧，我要感谢Spence博士今天加入我的节目。这真是太棒了，现在我饿了，我得去找点吃的。谢谢。你可以在我们的网站speakingofpsychology.org或Apple、Spotify、YouTube或任何你获取播客的地方找到《心理学谈话》之前的剧集。
And if you like what you've heard, please subscribe and leave it. review. If you have comments or ideas for future episodes, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of Psychology is produced by Lee Wynerman. Thank you for listening to the American Psychological Association. I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如果你喜欢你所听到的，请订阅并留下评论。如果你对未来的剧集有评论或想法，你可以发送电子邮件至speakingofpsychology@apa.org。《心理学谈话》由Lee Wynerman制作。感谢收听美国心理学会的节目。我是Kim Mills。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。